[Música]
bruno santamaría un gusto tenerte con
nosotros aquí en radio canadá
internacional
gracias muchas gracias el gusto es mío
bruno bueno tú eres cineasta y esa es la
idea de esta entrevista sin contarnos la
película tuya cosas que no hacemos que
se presentarán en el festival hot docs
de documentales de la ciudad de toronto
y cosas que no hacemos habla de secretos
porque a tu juicio es importante hablar
de los secretos
en particular en este caso digamos que
era el secreto de arturo
siento que era algo que al no
compartirlo con otras personas
vivir de manera abierta estaba pidiendo
estoy pidiendo que absurdo pues creciera
de alguna forma una vez que él se libera
cuenta el permiso el permiso para
para poder hacer lo que quiera hacer en
la vida
vivió un proceso de maduración y
crecimiento que le permite liberarse y
poder empezar a irnos de interactuar ya
no solo con niños sino con gente dada a
relacionarse ya desarrollarse e incluso
profesionalmente no ahora está dando
clases en la primaria y kínder a los
niños y siento que de manera todo está
liberado ver nuestros y desbloqueó que
tenía el crecimiento y su maduración y
está enseñando a y en el roblito sigue
instando a los niños del kinder
pues no sé de cuestiones de guardias de
aprender a jugar pero ya habíamos
completa la libertad de identidad cuando
quiere el techo que está empezando un
proceso hormonal y arturo para hacer
estallar
y bruno porque crees tú que sea
necesario liberarse de los secretos
porque tenemos una concepción muy
particular de los secretos no seas algo
que nos rebelamos porque crees que es
necesario esa liberación
o dos
en particular este secreto era algo que
tiene que ver sus represiones sociales
con profesiones familiares que son
secretos que te obliga digamos de otra
forma la sociedad a guardar y que
impiden o imposibilita digamos que uno
pueda hacer pleno y feliz quien uno
quiere ser quizá yo replico en secretos
e incluso a veces a no guardar de una
manera que no se dé
pero en el caso de arturo siento que era
un secreto que no tenía por qué estar
guardando de hecho es absurdo es una
especie de protección quizás no porque
la sociedad se manifiesta de forma
violenta cuando no se puede decidir ese
tipo de mujer en una fiesta porque les
incomoda porque nos han enseñado que la
religión está mal
todd alguna manera creo que este tipo de
decretos eso solamente solo con una
representación de no violentar y lo
reactiva que es la sociedad entonces eso
me parece importantísimo o liberarse de
ellos
justamente bruno puesto que habla de la
violencia tú dices que quería filmar en
un lugar donde se sintiera de primera
mano la violencia que se vive en méxico
porque en ese contexto
si es un proceso de transformación me
parece interesante en un principio
digamos todo empezó en la película de
alguna forma un poco inconsciente pero
porque yo también tenía un secreto y
estaba buscando un lugar donde poder
abrir esto para quizá después eso no
tener el secreto de alguna manera
pensaba secreto para madurar
o quizá madurar y hacer esta película y
un viaje de mera contra el secreto y
sentía que para crecer en un país en un
contexto hace falta ser crítico entender
la realidad y pensaba que la violencia
en méxico que es algo de lo que se habla
muchísimo la violencia de crímenes
atroces mensajes importantes de tener
una reflexión y vivir de ser que digamos
de nueva forma de esta realidad para
poder entenderla porque no entonces
pensaba que sinaloa el primer lugar que
fui con una amiga era un espacio para
poderlo sentir y bueno muchas
casualidades llegamos al roblito
y todo lo contrario lo que habíamos
imaginado no se siente ninguna iglesia
todo lo contrario he hecho un hábito
adulto que aquí en el pueblo y vasto que
nos quedáramos a dormir un par de noches
ahí para entender que quizá una de las
violencias más fuertes que se vive en
este pueblo era la ausencia de adultos
justo porque están todo el tiempo
trabajando tanto las mujeres como los
hombres ya sea en la casa o fuera de la
casa pasan todo el tiempo trabajando los
hombres en particular los pescadores que
son pescadores y construyen campamentos
fuera de sus casas a los que tienen que
emigrar digamos por temporadas largas
para poder pescar entonces rezando con
ilusión han logrado de pronto están
meses y meses fuera además también en el
roblito hay una escasez de agua brutal
hay su columna imaginad muy alejado de
todos me lleva muy poco tiempo donde una
mano empezamos a entender que hay un
montón de violencias no sólo las más
visibles que ocurren en los espacios
pero comprometer pasando el tiempo de
alguna manera hubo una conexión que
apareció digamos de una manera muy
accidentada
y que ver con una violencia igual de
grande pero representada en la violencia
que está viviendo en secreto para no ser
violado por marcos y dar forma entonces
de alguna manera afirma entendiendo que
hay un montón de comparativamente mente
de violencia en un espacio y sin embargo
bueno todo esto por parte del contexto
una película está presente pero el eje
central digamos estar de esta violencia
que impide que este niño digamos termine
de crecer a decidir si será abierta una
mujer
y podríamos decir bruno que cosas que no
hacemos es un drama psicológico
si yo no lo he pensado mucho no no creo
que todo el proceso de hacer la película
fue muy intuitivo toda la construcción
de la historia estoy haciendo mente
estamos en el rodaje cita las ministra
andrea la transmitiste yo y después
montando lo fue un proceso casi de
liberación compartidos no digamos al
igual que arturo no comentaba en un
principio que tiene un proceso de
transformación y de crecimiento
de la misma forma yo como director
estaba en un proceso similar también
empieza a tener un novio por primera vez
en mi vida y entonces empezó a ser un
compartir y encuentro conversaciones
charlas incluso filmar sueños no le
preguntamos arturo qué es lo que tú
quisieras vivir si soñadas lo podíamos
firmar y nos dijo pues vestirme de mujer
entonces la secuencia en donde él se
viste mujer fue planeada como un sueño
es decir una serie de comunicaciones a
partir de necesidades vitales de dos
personas dejen vivir expresar y evitar
de manera libre lo que quieren ser y
surgió una película creo que sí digamos
todo está contenido en el secreto y es
una opción interior entonces por
supuesto que la psicología y sobre todo
en esa secuencia de nueva gramática de
la que no voy a hablar para que la
puedan ver en la película hay una
atención psicológica ante lo que está
pasando entre la mamá el papá arturo
nuestra triángulo de atención que se
construye en donde la cama estaba en
medio que es la secuencia más dramática
que haríamos de la película
pero bueno todo esto para decir que no
lo pensé en realidad muchos
pero si tiene características de una
película
muy bien la historia bruno transcurre en
un pueblito que se llama el roblito o
roblito pero antes de comenzar a filmar
antes de comenzar a rodar
tú tu película tú empezaste dando clases
de vídeo a los niños y las niñas de
rovito cómo fue esa experiencia
si todo surgió en principio porque
estábamos conjuntamente en sinaloa
fuimos a una cantina en un centro
botanero que son unas islas en una zona
de manglares entre la frontera de
nayarit y sinaloa y un niño nos contó
que cada navidad sobrevuela la isla
distinta que los aventando de dulces a
los niños y esa idea se quedó muy
grabada en la cabeza
la difusión antes de alguna manera
necesitábamos encontrar un pretexto para
estar con justificación norte en la isla
en donde apareció la idea de dar clases
en la primaria los niños de alguna
manera esto nos presentaba con las mamás
con los papás pero con las maestras y
los forestadores nacidos 10
empezamos a hacer cartas que presentaban
ellos escribían quienes salieran que les
gusta hacerlo y esas cartas se
transformaban en guiones la idea
original era poder llevar esta carta esa
ciudad de mexico y canción de mis otros
niños escribieron cartas hacia ella pero
terminó más bien siendo una forma de que
los niños grabarán con el celular de un
juego dentro de las clases en la
primaria como todos guiándolos y esas
cartas vídeo cartas editado nos damos
trabajo con las familias y les gustó
tanto la experiencia de archivo
equilibrando que surgió quizá después
hay la idea de empezar a mostrar
película dentro del pueblo
una noches y una noche
desde ccoo a chaplin o margarita error
que fue mi primer película documental
que para mí es muy importante también
porque es cierto que nos dejó muy en
claro qué es lo que estaba si nosotros
en el pueblo es decir quienes no y qué
tipo de cine que es el cine documental
donde las personas que aparecen en la
pantalla existe en la vida real los de
alguna manera creo que esta dinámica
generó mucha empatía y alguna también
empezó a
a prepararnos no para hacer la película
las dos cosas tanto a mostrar la
película como hacen las clases de vídeo
fue una dinámica que nos acercó mucho a
la población y el balón aluminio es
también estudios muy inquietos y
ansiosos por ser parte de una película
en bruno ya para terminar lo decíamos al
principio tu película fue seleccionada
para ser presentada en el festival hot
docs de la ciudad de toronto como fue
como ocurrió eso
a ti
la película estuvo seleccionada en un
working progress en el festival de los
campos del premium es que se le presenta
en una sala de cine a varios programados
programadores de diversos festivales no
al que invita el festival y en ese
espacio
ahí estaba header game que es
programadora jefa del área documentales
hot docs vimos la película por la vida y
ella se conmovió mucho hablamos después
ahora sobre la película y estamos en
contacto ser cuatro meses más o menos y
ya nos pone en contacto con varios
programadores más de del festival en un
principio la película iba a ser parte
del bafici como festival en buenos aires
o blogs en guadalajara y en ambulante de
costes reales en méxico exportado la
contingencia a favor se vino para abajo
o se propuso y hot docs sacó esta
plataforma online para hacer el festival
se atrasó un poco y vamos a ver estuvo
10 días disponible para prensa y
personas acreditadas y el festival
ocurrió el 28 de mayo aparece el 10 de
junio que va a estar a disposición para
toda la zona de notario
la película disponible más buenos del
proceso de explicar los ajos tops
bueno la comunicación se nos está
dañando bruno muchísimas gracias
en esta entrevista a radio canadá
internacional recuerdo que tú eres el
director de la película del documental
cosas que no hacemos y que será
presentada en el festival hot docs de la
ciudad de toronto muchísimas gracias
gracias
[Música]